Guten Morgen Minus. Guten Morgen Tim. Bist du wieder da? Ja. Aus dem Off.
Guten Morgen Dino. Guten Morgen Tim. Bist du wieder da? Ja. Ja.
Hast du das Gefühl, irgendwas verpasst zu haben.
Äh nein, es ist.
Ich war ja auch irgendwie weg. Und habe nix mitbekommen. Und dann kommt man so wieder und dann ist auf einmal wieder alles in Flammen. Türkei,
Flut und ja und die Medien unterhalten sich über ein Thema, wo ich mir die ganze Zeit dachte, so,
Hm, gab's eigentlich irgendwelche Informationen, die wir hier nicht schon seit zwei Jahren hin und her äh besprochen haben so. Alle, alle werden überwacht. Hm, ja.
Die USA haben gegoogelt, der Google äh kooperiert mit äh mit den nationalen Sicherheitsbehörden.
Ja, die Geheimdienste sorgen irgendwie Firmen aus, hm, ja. Was war jetzt nochmal gleich die Nachricht?
Ich also das.
So ging's dir auch.
Ja, natürlich, es ist so, also im im Prinzip ist das so, äh diese diese äh Situation, ne? Es gab es war ganz offensichtlich.
Die Verschwörungstheoretiker haben's ja immer schon gesagt und wurden dafür belächelt.
Aber jetzt, wo der, wo jetzt sind, im Prinzip endlich die Belege auf dem Tisch so, jetzt steht's auch, jetzt ist es nicht mehr nur äh offensichtlich, sondern belegt.
Und jetzt kann man sagen, ähm also in einiger Zeit wird man sagen, das haben wir ja schon immer so gewusst. Das war schon, also wie äh.
Wie ich das jetzt unbedingt mit die Erde ist, eine Kugel vergleichen, aber so ein paar Idioten haben immer gesagt, die Erde ist eine Kugel. Und als sie's dann endlich bewiesen hatten, äh war's halt aufs ja, klar, haben wir ja schon, sagen wir schon seit einiger Zeit, so, weißt du? Offensichtlich.
Ja. Gut, aber so oder so, du bist jetzt auch wieder da. Weil du bist ja mal nicht da gewesen, bisher sozusagen abgängig gewesen.
Jetzt bin ich wieder da, ja.
Ja genau, aber du bist hier wirklich vertreten worden.
Ich war ich war sehr begeistert. Ich äh habe äh lange daran rumformuliert, einen wie wie man es in einen Tweet presst ähm dass ich hoffe, dass die Sendung auch, wenn ich,
nicht dabei bin, so informationsreich ist, weil das war echt äh also es war sehr, ich habe da viel gelernt, weil war völlig überrascht, also könnte sein, dass also vielleicht machen, also ich hoffe, dass dass wir auch ähm,
äh dass uns das auch gelingt.
Ja, ja, du bist jetzt auch erstmal gesetzt und so, also schmeißt dich nicht gleich.
Ja, ich habe schon gedacht, so scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße.
Ja, also Lokbuch-Netzpolitik ist wieder da, siebenundsechzig in letzter Zeit mit etwas unruhigen, unruhigen Veröffentlichungs äh Rhythmus. Äh das,
nicht unbedingt so weitergehen, sondern das war einfach mal den Umständen geschuldet. Ja.
Dann kommen wir eigentlich auch gleich einsteigen, oder?
Einsteigen. Es ging los. Soll ich sagen, soll ich sagen, wie's losging?
Ja, sag mal, wie es losging.
Es ging los mit dem mit dem League eines Gerichtsurteil, das Verizen ohne Einschränkungen äh die Kommunikations
Meterdaten herausgeben muss, also die Rufnummern beider Anschlüsse für jedes Telefonat, ortsbezogene Daten sowie Dauer und Uhrzeit, der Anrufe muss an die NSA geben.
In den USA, genau, wer es noch nicht mitbekommen hat, Horizon ist so der größte Mobilfunkanbieter
Hm, also ich weiß nicht, ob's jetzt wirklich unterm Strich die Größen sind, aber ich glaube, sie haben tatsächlich noch einen Tick mehr Subscriber als äh AT. So ein bisschen so wie hier mit Telekom und Vodafone ist das so ein bisschen mit Horizon und ATNT.
In den USA. Ja und ähm welches Gericht hat da geurteilt eigentlich.
Ich weiß nicht genau, welches Gericht das war, aber äh interessanter ist die Begründung, denn das Gericht sagte, ja ähm es äh,
Also Verizon soll diese Daten g rausgeben. Äh und der Grund ist, es handelt sich ja nur um die Transaktionsdaten, nicht um die Inhalte und daher ist kein Einzelbeschluss pro beteiligte Person notwendig. Das war die Frage
um die sich da in den USA gestritten wurde. Das also Horizon Wire äh Verizon gesagt hat, ja ähm Freunde,
wenn wir das machen, dann braucht ihr aber doch einen äh Beschluss dafür, ne. Und ähm das war quasi, das wurde da verhandelt und die,
es wurde weiterhin verhandelt über den, über einen Datensatz von einem Zeitspanne von drei Monaten. Und wie dem wie dem.
Aufmerksam äh Bürger äh sicherlich nicht entgangen ist, das ist äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das ist genau wie wir sie in der äh EU als äh äh EU-weit gelten haben und eigentlich nur noch in in Deutschland debattieren,
und loswerden wollen und in den, in Deutschland sind das sechs Monate.
Ja, oder oder sollen es sechs Monate sein? Diese drei Monatefrist, das ist ja das, wo in äh in die Richtung äh äh das Justizministerium da noch so ein bisschen
irgendwie die versucht einzudämmen und so, die genaue Gemengelage ist da unklar. Aber das ist oder ist da momentan unklar, aber genau das ist Forester entsprechend. Dann haben wir
Deutschland. Können wir einen harten Winter machen.
Den Europäer auch mit Stolz zu wissen, dass man zumindest im Bereich der Telekommunikation in den USA noch voraus ist.
Richtig,
Da denke ich auch, da können wir einfach mal äh Ort äh stolz die Flagge zeigen, dass äh wir solche Gerichtsurteile solche Streitereien erfüllen bei uns schon lange nicht mehr,
andererseits interessant, also äh beruft sich die USA bei dieser bei dieser ganzen Aktion auf ihren Patreot-Act, der ist ja schon von zweitausendeins, glaube ich, äh Patriot-Act Zeit.
Das war so Post, Nine Deleven.
Ja ähm war das also wahrscheinlich noch zweitausendeins oder äh dann spätestens zweitausendzwei. Ich kann ja mal ganz kurz gucken. Patreat act ähm.
Zweitausendeins, ja. Äh,
ja? Äh zu intersep and abstrakte Terrawisen. Das war der Patrick und der ist die äh der der soll dann auch die Basis für diese für diese äh Sache da sein,
Und ähm da kann man dann, da kommt dann dieses schöne ähm.
Sage ich später noch was zu. Also, das war jetzt erstmal so der der erste Punkt. Und ähm das das zündete natürlich schon einigermaßen in den USA, dass man sich dachte, ah, seid ihr wahnsinnig und so, ne? Aber ähm
durch den Begriff Transaktionsdaten und so konnte man das ausreichend äh offen Niveau heben, wo der durchschnittliche IQ eines
Amerikaners aufhört, sodass man da jetzt irgendwie nicht großartig ähm,
noch nicht so den großen Skandal hatte. Und dann kam diese diese Wahnsinnsveröffentlichung, das nämlich seit zweitausendsieben,
Die NSA ein äh Programm mit dem Namen Prisum unterhält. Prisum wie das Prisma,
und ähm das besteht hauptsächlich daraus, dass sie bei den äh bei vielen großen ähm.
Computer und Internetanbietern namentlich Microsoft Yawu, Google, Facebook, keine Ahnung, YouTube, Skype, AOL und seit Oktober zweitausendzwölf auch Apple. Ähm,
und echtzeit Kommunikation in ihren Zugriff,
haben. Also das heißt, sie können E-Mail, Video und äh Audiochats, Videos, Fotos, Voice over IP ähm Datenübertragung, Profile und Details in sozialen Netzwerken und mehr.
Ähm einsehen.
Und das ist jetzt die äh das ist das war's eigentlich auch schon, ja. Also die Großen, die großen Provider oder die großen Diensteanbieter der USA, arbeiten mit der äh National Security Agency zusammen.
Ja und das Ganze war ein Leak von einem Edward Snowden, von dem die Welt vorher so noch nichts wusste,
der äh wenn ich das richtig sehe bei der NSA gearbeitet hat, ne und.
Sub Contractor, wenn ich das richtig.
Ein war und der äh das irgendwie nicht so geil fand und sich jetzt irgendwie nach Hongkong abgesetzt hat so in der Hoffnung, da äh irgendwie,
einer heilen Haut davon zu kommen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit dessen wird, glaube ich, gemeinhin als gering eingestuft.
Aus der Nummer rauskommt. Ja, aber ist doch jetzt in die freie Welt geflohen.
Ach China.
Julien Assange äh Julian Assange legte ihm ja äh Asyl in äh politisches Asyl,
Ja oder zumindest in in äh äh Süd- oder Lateinamerika, nah? Ja. Weil, also das, ich muss es.
So lange er sich noch ausgereist bekommt, ja.
Jetzt aber schnell nach Ecuador.
Ja, aber im Prinzip ist das nicht unbedingt jetzt eine Kopie,
Das Bradley Mennings äh Ding, aber ich schätze mal, äh dass jetzt auch dieses Leak auf einem ähnlichen Level eingestuft werden dürfte,
die äh Autoritäten in den USA und äh dass der junge Mann jetzt nicht unbedingt mit so viel Zuspruch und einer äh Zukunft in den USA äh rechnen kann.
Also berufliche Zukunft innerhalb der USA, schlechte Karten im Moment, ähm ich denke auch sonst, also der wird sich mit dem Gedanken anfreunden müssen, dass er dieses Land nicht mehr.
Kann.
Also er kann's bestimmt betreten.
Ja klar, aber es ist ihm, dass,
dass er, wenn er nochmal in die USA kommt, dann ist er in tiefer Scheiße. Entweder äh weil sie ihn dahin geholt haben oder weil weil sie ihn dann da sich schnappen werden.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Hongkong so 'ne, so 'ne, meine Wahl wäre, wenn ich mich vor den USA verstecken soll, ich hab da, wollte aber, ich hab da so 'ne Einschätzung gelesen, wo einige meinten, das wär jetzt gar nicht so, äh, ungünstig.
Also es wäre ja nicht damit zu rechnen, dass China sich den äh den Ärger mit Hongkong,
Handeln wollen würde, weil Honkung ja diese Freihandelszone ist und,
zwar theoretisch, den sich dort schnappen und ausweisen, äh an, an die USA ausweisen könnte, dass hier aber sich wahrscheinlich den, den ähm,
Ärger mit Hongkong da irgendwie nicht geben wollen, weil da ist irgendwie in letzter Zeit ganz ganz befriedeter diese ganze Ecke, äh keine Ahnung, was da also ich kann das nicht, ich kenne die die politische Situation dann nicht ausreichen, um äh,
bewerten zu können, wie sicher er in Hongkong ist. Der wird da wahrscheinlich aber darüber nachgedacht haben.
Das wollte ich auch gerade meinen, also er wird darüber nachgedacht haben, nur was heißt das schon, ne? Also so oder so sind äh einfach seine Möglichkeiten, da sehr eingeschränkt in Zukunft äh irgendwas zu machen und äh,
also äh das zeugt auf jeden Fall schon von einer gewissen Überzeugung, die ihn dort geleitet hat,
Jetzt gibt's halt viel Aufhebens äh in den Medien. Ähm es wird auch, sagen wir mal, noch ein weiteres Mal, auf die NSA geblickt, die ja vor nicht allzu langer Zeit auch noch komplett,
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange ist das her? Erinnerst dich noch? Also die NSA, die Existenz der NSE wurde ja vor gar nicht so langer Zeit komplett bestritten.
Also das ist dieses dieses Gruppe überhaupt gibt, war ja sozusagen nicht unbedingt äh.
Teil der öffentlichen Diskussion.
Oh, das muss aber, also sie existiert seit irgendwie seit den fünfziger Jahren. Ich weiß nicht, ob's eine Zeit lang da noch geheim war, aber.
AO, in den vierziger Jahren als Unterabteilung des äh Department of Defense geschaffen äh und dann irgendwie ein paar Mal umbenannt. Ähm.
Da weiß ich gar nicht genau, ob das, ob's da irgendwie so genau kenne ich die Geschichte nicht.
Kann ich jetzt auf jeden Fall auch nicht aus auswendig äh runterbieten. Das hat sich auf jeden Fall vor einiger Zeit geändert. Und ähm ich meine, die USA,
sind ja auch nicht arm an Geheimdiensten. Also ich finde das schon überhaupt absurd.
Die haben zu viele.
Wie viele unterschiedliche Geheimdienste es da überhaupt gibt, ja? Also erstmal fragt man sich ja sowieso, warum braucht man überhaupt mehr als einen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist das ist schon klar, also die jedes Land hat hier zumindest einen Inlands und ein Auslandsgeheimdienst,
die unterliegen auch unterschiedlichen Regulationen. Das ist auch jetzt eine große äh genau die große Frage bei dieser oder die für die für die USA jetzt gerade die Frage mit dieser NSA. Und zwar ist das der
Militärnachrichtendienst. Das heißt, die haben nur irgendwo Finger drin zu haben bei bei nicht,
Amerikanern. Und ähm.
Darum dreht sich jetzt im Wesentlichen auch die Aufmerksamkeit.
Genau darum dreht sich nämlich die Aufmerksamkeit, weil die ganzen Libatieren, das ist interessant, das jetzt eigentlich hast du jetzt die die linken, progressiven,
sage ich mal äh Datenschützer, Liberalen,
Äh Leute, die irgendwie eine offene Demokratie glauben äh und gleichzeitig aber diese libertären,
dass hier so eine sowas diese limitäre Fraktion, die gibt's ja eigentlich in in Deutschland, Europa nicht so stark, wie es die in USA gibt. Also die Leute, die sagen, wir wollen halt äh ein ganz, ganz ähm,
Wir wollen einen schmalen Staat haben, wir wollen irgendwie Waffenrechte haben, wir wollen so möglich wie so wenig wie möglich
dass irgendwo die Regierung eingreift, was aber gleichzeitig aber das mit sehr starken konservativen Idealen verbinden und,
sich natürlich dann auch so diese kranken äh Auswüchse des Kapitalismus dazu auch äh gerne noch äh mit in Kauf nehmen,
Und deren Hauptargument ist ja eigentlich, äh dass er so sagen so American Stone Spye on Americans. Ja, es gab diesen spannenden Vortrag, du hast ihn vielleicht gesehen beim äh neunundzwanzig C drei, wo dieser Thomas Drake äh NSA-Aussteiger.
Da über äh die über die Auswüchse des äh der NSA schon ähm dann da referiert und geklagt hat. Dass aber aus dieser diese ganze Zeit diese Inbrunst ähm,
Das das äh,
das das guten Patrioten ja? Und dass das alles also alles irgendwie nur deshalb verwerflich fand, weil er doch Amerikaner ist.
Und sich nicht irgendwie übers Gesamt. Also es war das einzige, was ihn daran aufgeregt hat, ja? Und genau das das ähm beschäftigt jetzt auch gerade die USA,
Ähm das ist früher ein Foren äh Intelligence zu Valence Act,
gab oft auf dessen Basis die NSA oder den gibt's immer noch, aber früher war das die Basis der Arbeit des äh NSA und da mussten sie,
Pro Überwachungsvorgang äh jeweils eine eine Autoorisierung haben und bestätigen, dass alle Beteiligten äh Kommunikationspartner außerhalb der USA sind.
Und mit dieser äh mit dem Prison reicht es für sie, dass sie einen begründeten äh Verdacht haben, dass,
Eine der Kommunikations äh Parteien außerhalb der USA war zu der Zeit, an dem äh die.
Aufnahme äh gesammelt wurde. Das heißt, du hast jetzt als als US-Amerikaner, der mit einem äh Menschen kommuniziert, der sich nicht innerhalb der USA befindet, eine sehr bist du schon fällst du in dieses Raster und äh.
Ferngespräch.
Ja, sagen wir mal Fernesprecher, dann dann wäre das jetzt nach aktueller Arbeitsgrundlage der NSA äh würden sie dann sich berechtigt sehen dort, ähm.
Also mit einer wollten sie biegen das so, wie sie's brauchen, damit sie möglichst viel abgreifen können und ähm.
Genau, aber also ist doch eigentlich völlig unerheblich, ob das jetzt Amerikaner sind oder andere, weil natürlich in der in dieser Struktur dieses Geheimnis ist das eine sehr entscheidende Frage. Weil's eben ein äh ja ein Militärnachrichtendienst ist.
Aber ist jetzt vor allem auch, äh geht weit jetzt über diese eigentliche VDS äh Dimension hinaus. Hier geht's auch wirklich um die Inhalte. Hier geht's quasi um alles.
Also da reden wir von äh Zugriff auf, wie wie sagt man das immer so schön? Ich hatte mir das sogar nochmal extra notiert. Also im Prinzip ähm,
Zugriff auf einmal die Daten, die auf den Servern liegen und uns Zugriff auf die,
Also gespeicherte Kommunikation, sagen wir mal die E-Mails auf meinem Google Mailserver,
Ich bin ja auch betroffen davon. Ich habe einen äh habe ein Google Konto, da ist äh sind auch E-Mails drin. Das werden dann eben gespeicherte Daten und auch auf die Echtzeit Kommunikation. Das ist dann eben der Fall ähm,
Skype oder so, ne? Skype speichert nicht, sondern die machen halt äh Live-Verbindung oder oder Facetime, ja? Deswegen ist sicherlich Apple da mit drin.
Und ähm da haben die halt überall irgendwie ihren Zugriff zu. Das ist auch äh offensichtlich nicht eine Standardisierte Sache, sondern so wie sich hier diese Folien, die der Guardian da äh gelegt hat mit Hilfe von dem
Snowden äh steht dann so, dass sie sagen so ähm in der Regel äh bekommst du das,
hier, was hier steht, aber äh Mayvery äh bei Provider. Also aber so sie sagen halt E-Mail-Chat, Videos und so weiter, je nachdem. Also du bekommst natürlich keine ähm,
Videokonferenzen von einem Dienst, der keine anbietet, ja. Also grob haben sie das hingekriegt. Und.
Das ist natürlich jetzt irgendwie, also natürlich ist das ein ein enormes Lied, dass das in diesem Ausmaß rauskommt und das Ausmaß dieser Überwachung,
übertrifft sicherlich ein das was viele Menschen,
sich da ausgemalt haben, insgesamt ist das aber, kann man da jetzt nicht wirklich davon reden, dass das äh besonders überraschend ist. Es gab da eine sehr schöne Zahl, dass dieses die jährlichen Kosten für dieses Prison-Programm sind zwanzig Millionen Dollar.
Dass.
Geschätzte jährliche Budget der NSA, die der äh finanziell am solidesten ausgestattetste äh Geheimnis der USA ist, sind Aid Billion. Und jetzt muss ich mich nochmal äh, ist er, wie ist das nochmal, dieser Bild, die.
Acht Milliarden US-Dollar.
Acht Milliarden US-Dollar und zwanzig Millionen davon, also so quasi ein Rundungsfehler davon, äh brauchen sie für diese Prisum-Sache.
Ja, Taschengeld. Klingt aber sehr wenig, zwanzig.
Ja, da werden sicherlich nicht die äh ganzen Personalkosten für die Analysten mit drin sein.
Technische Aufwand.
Würde schätzen, dass das der,
Technische, sagen wir mal Gerätekosten, aufrechterhaltung und Administration oder so, Ausbau äh solche Dinge betrifft, also die Infrastruktur und die Wartung der Infrastruktur, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Spike Cloud.
Also wenn du sagst, da sind jetzt, was waren das zehn, größere äh Provider, waren da, glaube ich, mit an Bord. Eine zwei, vier
sechs, neun. Wenn du sagst, zwei Millionen, was kannst du mit zwei Millionen bei einem Provider machen, kannst du halt eine ordentliche Infrastruktur da hinstellen, äh kannst die warten.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das schon der komplette Analystenapparat auch noch mit drin ist in den zwanzig Millionen, denn sie haben bisher siebenundsiebzigtausend Intelligence-Reports äh verfasst in den,
Programm irgendwie, also dieses Prison-Programm äh berücksichtigt wurde. Sie haben äh.
Ja, es ist nee, in den Informationen, die daher kamen, äh verwendet irgendwie, also das sind tausend, die sind immer nur Zahlen mit vielen Nullen, ja.
Ja, aber es gibt jetzt auch keine Erkenntnisse, äh inwiefern diese ganze Überwachung jetzt schon wirklich irgendwas gebracht hat.
Nee, da bin ich mal gespannt. Da werden sie, würde ich jetzt vermuten, je nachdem, wie lange die Sache gespinnt wird, werden die USA da eventuell mit irgendwelchen Beispielen, also wird die Regierung da mit irgendwelchen Beispielen vortreten,
und sagen hier, den Obama hätten wir niemals ohne das Ding erschießen können, weil der hat äh ein G mehr Konto gehabt oder so, irgend so ein Quatsch, werden sich wahrscheinlich noch einfallen lassen.
Würde ich jetzt so erwarten.
Weiterer interessanter Spin war ja, dass in der, in der konservativen US Presse, man muss ja jetzt irgendwie einen Grund finden, diesen Messenger da zu erschießen, ne? Also man muss ja jetzt irgendwie dem dem Snowden irgendwie noch äh den,
Äh
Und einen schwarzen Peter zu.
Irgendeinen schwarzen Peter zuschieben und da waren ja dann auch schon, wurden ja dann die Stimmen laut, die sagten, der Skandal ist nicht, dass der ähm,
dass dass die NSA das macht, sondern dass der Snowden jetzt äh äh mit der mit den Operationen dieses Militärgeheimdienstes Dienstes äh interferiert, indem er das bekannt macht, ja? Und da da äh wird natürlich schon das,
Gewetzt um den Mann irgendwie noch einen schwarzen Peter zuschieben zu können. Was vermutlich in der, in der US äh Öffentlichkeit.
Äh dann auch äh gelingen wird. Die ist ja nicht durch besonderes Reflexionsvermögen äh bisher aufgefallen.
Ja auch,
ist es immer wieder erstaunlich zu sehen, dass in den USA auch dieses ganze Überwachungsthema irgendwie gar nicht so richtig greift, also was ja vorhin schon ganz schön,
diesen merkwürdigen Interessen, Überschneidungsbereich genannt mit so diesen Hardcore Rightwing Leuten, ja, die sozusagen in so in dieser Illusion von
Na ja, äh wir waren jetzt die Ersten, die mit unseren Planwagen hier in den Westen äh gefahren sind und wurden dann jahrhundertelang äh im Wesentlichen in Ruhe gelassen und so
Washington.
Das ist weit weg, ja? Das ist so, ja, da werden so ein paar Regeln gemacht irgendwie, wie so der Handel. Äh in den Häfen zu laufen hat, so mit Europa, aber es betrifft uns irgendwie nicht groß und sind immer noch total beseelt davon, ne? Auf der anderen Seite
kippt's dann irgendwie schnell wieder um, wenn dann sozusagen so Amerika als Ganzes sich von was weiß immer, äh was weiß ich, auch bedroht sieht, ja, äh Aliens, dem Islam,
oder sonst irgendwas. Äh dann schieben sie alles.
In diese Zentralisierung rein und dann darf da auch aus vollen Rohren gefeuert werden. Also es,
irgendwie von mit unserer europäischen Brille natürlich auch alles nicht so zusammen. Ich glaube, dass dieser eigentliche Bürger,
Rechtsanteil, den wir da gerne ausmachen wollen in einer starken Minderheit ist,
Ich habe ja jetzt auch was von gehört, dass ich gerade mal so paar und fünfzig Prozent hier überhaupt aufregen über die ganze Nummer.
Was sagte, äh was war Obamas äh erstes Code dazu, dass er sagte, du kannst nicht hundert Prozent Sicherheit, hundert Prozent Datenschutz und.
Hundert Prozent so und so haben. Also ähm ja, müsste ich jetzt. Ja, aber äh aber äh.
Mein Lieblingssatz der deutschen Politik. Hundertprozentige Sicherheit kann's nicht geben. Ich bin da ein eine Kerbe in ein Holz geschnitzt hätte, da wäre wahrscheinlich von dem Holz nicht viel übrig geblieben.
Was es spannend ist, dass er, ja, hier habe ich das cool
Spannend ja ähm
Du kannst aber auch mit null Prozent Privacy keine hundertprozent Security bekommen, ja? Also das ist halt der äh das ähm.
Na gut, also ich meine, da kann man jetzt äh,
Können wir jetzt beliebig weit ähm das Fass äh öffnen hier und äh die Generaldiskussionen führen, ne, also was
was will ein Staat, was soll ein Staat dürfen, um äh diese Sicherheit herzustellen, ja, das ist äh
und hängt sehr von der eigenen Gemengelage ab, was man da als angemessen empfindet oder nicht angemessen empfindet. Was ich jetzt bloß irgendwie krass finde, ist,
In USA wird halt vor allem einfach irgendwie gemacht. Es gibt so ein paar ähm schwammige,
Vorlagen, aus denen du im Prinzip alles ableiten kannst, wie diesen Patriot Act. Nach dem Motto, ja, alles, was jetzt hier zum Schutz nötig ist, darf mal gemacht werden im Wesentlichen. Und dann wird halt einfach auch,
und ich würde ja noch nicht mal sagen, dass wir jetzt hier schon am Ende ähm des Fasses angekommen sind, also es ist vielleicht jetzt,
bei einer Irredimension, aber es ist bestimmt nicht das einzige, äh was in den USA von,
Government durchgeführt wird, von dem die Öffentlichkeit so nichts weiß. Wir sind nicht in so ein Verschwörungs äh theoretischen Bereich vordringen, aber äh das ist hier so ein Disconnect zu geben scheint mit dem worüber äh die Öffentlichkeit wirklich klar
in Kenntnis gesetzt wird und was was tatsächlich läuft, das das scheint mir offensichtlich zu sagen.
Spannende Sache dazu ist natürlich noch, dass das alles irgendwie äh eigentlich nur ähm,
Also seinen Ursprung hatte in der in der Bus-Administration, der größere Teil des Ausbaus, aber dann ähm,
und die Nutzung in der äh Obama-Administration stattgefunden hat. Das heißt, das was äh also das das große zentrale äh Wahlversprechen Obamas, was viele Menschen da eben auch bewegt hat, ähm,
Würde ja eine eine Einstellung oder Verminderung von solchen Techniken durchaus äh,
nahelegen aber das das Gegenteil ist offensichtlich der Fall. Gleichzeitig hat ja Obama mehr in der Gasse in der Obama äh Administration mehr Ärger für den,
unter der Administration aller anderen US-Präsidenten zusammen,
Ja, das heißt also, seine äh Gitter auch härter gegen Whistleblower vor, als ähm er das versprochen hat, hat ja ursprünglich mal betont, wie wichtig Whistleblower sind,
auf später nochmal kurz zu sprechen.
Und was war das Dritte, was ein Obama-Scheiße ist? Oh, keine Fäkalsprache. Ähm.
Ach so, nee, der, der, der, der weitere wichtige Punkt, also einer fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein. Was spannend ist, natürlich gibt es das in Deutschland auch und das muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz so zu sagen, es ist,
es ist einfach naiv zu glauben, dass äh irgendwelche Firmen in irgendeinem Land eine nennenswert große Kommunikationsinfrastruktur unterhalten
auf die Geheimdienste aus dem Inland und aus dem Ausland keinen Zugriff halten. Da sorgen die schon für,
Und in Deutschland ähm
gibt es das Gleiche, ein genau gleichlautendes Programm mit dem Namen strategische Fernmeldeaufklärung, das vom äh Bundesnachrichten äh Dienst betrieben wird, ja?
Also digitale Kommunikation irgendwie rastern, wir hatten hier sogar schon darüber berichtet. Das waren die, die irgendwann zweitausendelf ähm,
Kam da der letzte äh äh Bericht raus. Das waren die, die auf einmal so einen Anstieg hatten, weil zu viel Spam gab, ja? Die hatten äh hatten auf einmal eine Spam-Problematik und,
Das verriet dann auch, wo sie anzapfen, nämlich wenn sie quasi vor dem Spamfilter anzapfen, dann zapfen sie alles an,
und nicht erst äh irgendwie dahinter, quasi wenn die E-Mail schon im Postfach ist.
Trotzdem äh USA müssen sich warm anziehen, weil Merkel angekündigt hat, dass sie Prissen mit Obama besprechen will, ne.
Da wird's aber und hier äh Else Eigner kündigt ihren NSA-Account.
Ja du lass.
Die hat aber auch schon lange nichts mehr gepostet.
Das.
Also, ich habe da schon lange nichts mehr gelesen von ihr.
Äh währenddessen packt der ähm.
Packt der Norden übrigens immer noch mehr aus seinem Karton raus, der macht da jetzt gerade den den Guardian-Journalisten, glaube ich, zum
den macht er gerade unsterblich mit dem, was er da auspackt. Ähm jetzt gibt's da noch die Operations, wo sie also äh,
Im großen Stil auch äh äh in fremde Rechner und Netzwerke eindringen, Daten klauen, ähm,
Dann gibt es diese äh Bountles in Formenübersicht, wo erstaunlicherweise ausgerechnet Deutschland so ein roter Punkt da ist, dass äh dass also viele Deutsche betroffen sind von dieser NSA äh Spionage. Und was ja noch ein sehr schönes,
Seitennachricht war, wurde gar nicht so groß äh äh aufgehängt, dass irgendein ähm.
Eine junge Dame, die achtzehnjährige Jana äh die wollte nach ihrem Abitur als Auper in die USA. Und sie hat diese Verhandlung über diese Aupair äh äh Situation dann ähm selber äh organisiert über Facebook,
äh wo dann also sie eine Familie fand, die sagte, ja du kannst hier bei uns äh kannst bei uns wohnen, machst du Au-pair, kriegst du noch ein kleines Taschengeld äh und kostet und Regie. Und äh kümmerst dich dafür um die Kinder der Familie Aupair halt, ne? Nur dass
sie jetzt nicht bei irgendeiner Aupair Organisation gemacht, sondern eben über Facebook. Und äh dann kam sie in den USA an und wurde dann von der, von der Einwanderungsbehörde äh rausgewunken und äh sehr eindringlich gefragt, warum sie denn in die USA käme.
Und ähm schlussendlich äh weil sie denen natürlich nicht sagte, dass sie äh äh,
dass sie da jetzt eine Aupair machen möchte, sondern dass sie Freunde der Freunde besucht. Ähm und dann wurden, legten diese Beamten ihr äh ihre ausgedruckte Facebookkorrespondenz mit diesem Gastvater vor?
Und äh warfen ihr dann vor, sie plane hier äh illegal äh illegale Arbeit nachzugehen. Schwarz bezahlte Aupair Tätigkeit.
Noch Fragen, vielen Dank, dann können Sie sie jetzt zurückfliegen.
Und das ist natürlich spannend, weil die Einwanderung, also wenn das schon bei der, wenn irgendwie deine Facebook-Komplikation bei der Einwanderungsbehörde liegt, das ist natürlich schon.
Na gut, aber die ist ja auch genau,
an der Schnittstelle sozusagen, also keine Ahnung, wie da jetzt die offiziellen Verflechtungen sind, aber grad im Migration ist ja sozusagen einer der Haupt äh Abwehrschilde gegen äh Ein- und Ausreise und das ist da, auf dem der Ebene äh
hochgradigen Datenaustausch gibt, das, denke ich mal, ist unbezweifelt.
Aber da hätten wir auf jeden Fall schon mal unsere unsere Erfolgsgeschichte, ne? Schwarzarbeit von deutschen Aupair-Mädchen in den USA.
Mhm. Aber es ist äh wirklich interessant, finde ich, ähm dass man jetzt an solchen Fällen.
Es gibt ja auch noch viele andere Beispiele, aber so dieses lange Zeit so als theoretische Bedrohung äh,
angesehene Dingen, mit wenn du bei großen Plattformen bist oder überhaupt deiner Kommunikation nicht ausreichend absicherst, dann kann ja jemand mitlesen und das kann ja dann auch zu deinem Nachteil sein.
Wo ja viele dann immer wieder so mit diesen na ja.
Ich tue ja nichts Schlimmes. Äh mir kann da nichts passieren, bla, bla, bla, wer interessiert sich schon für mich, ja. Ich bin ja hier nur,
Mädchen was Aupair machen will. Ja und auf einmal ähm stellt man fest, dass man eben komplett durchleuchtet wird, wenn man nur einen,
wieso schätze mal, hier dürfte ein Visumsantrag äh vorangegangen sein für diesen langen äh Aufenthalt
Ja und in dem Moment kommt man dann sofort in den Datentrichter und dann wird einfach alles herangezogen, was in irgendeiner Form gemacht werden kann und da ja,
sagen wir mal jetzt die Dringlichkeit bei so einer Person,
aus welchem Land war die? Aus Deutschland? War die aus Deutschland? Ja. Ähm ja Deutschland gilt ja nicht unbedingt gerade jetzt als ähm.
Quell, na gut, kann man sehen, wie man will, also die Attentäter lebten ja auch in Deutschland. Ähm ja, aber grundsätzlich gilt ja Deutschland noch eher als, wie heißt denn das offiziell, äh nicht unbedingt vertrauenswürdiges Land, aber ähm.
Zumindest nicht als Feind.
Du kannst ja hier sozusagen generell erstmal auch ohne Visum einreisen oder hat sich das jetzt gerade geändert? Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht. Auf jeden Fall ähm.
Läuft Deutschland ja tendenziell eher noch unter Verbündete, sagen wir's mal so, ja?
Sodass man jetzt nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen kann, dass äh dieses Mädel
grundsätzlich schon längere Zeit als aktive Terroristen beobachtet wurde. Sprich, in dem Moment, wo das Visum gestellt wird, läuft dann äh mehr oder weniger so ein automatischer Check an und dann sind diese Daten schon da,
werden nicht erst recherchiert. Ja, sondern man weiß einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt schon so, ah, okay, hier, der Account, der könnte sein, zack,
Und dann sind die Daten einfach schon da und dann werden sie eben auch benutzt. Ne, schon ausreichend bedrohlich und es ist vor allem auch hm,
Interessante Frage, was das so für die Firmen eigentlich langfristig für eine Auswirkung hat. Weil wenn das jetzt einen zunehmenden Maße so hochbar wird, dass äh äh
Kommunikation in USA angeboten und gespeichert generell schon mal bedeutet, dass das alles zu deinem Nachteil sein kann.
Könnt es äh durchaus nochmal Standortvorteile geben, dadurch, dass man eben nicht Server in den USA betreibt.
Ja, also der,
versucht, das BSI ja äh wir hatten das glaube ich hier auch schon mal vor einem Jahr oder so behandelt. Das versuchen sie ja genau äh irgendwie mit ihr, wir machen jetzt hier Deutschland Cloud oder so, ne, ist aber die gleiche Soße in grün.
Deutschen Dienste dranhängen, ne. Ähm da muss man sich einfach keine,
Also da darf man sich einfach keine Illusionen hingeben und ähm das wurde jetzt hier mal gezeigt. Und es ist, ich find's dann auch sehr witzig, wenn sich jetzt dann da äh äh die Bundesrepublik irgendwie weit aus dem Fenster lehnt. Ähm
Da wird die Angela Merkel sicherlich auch nochmal ihr Memo äh bekommen
bevor sie da sich mit dem Obama äh an einen Tisch setzt und dem irgendwie einen eingießt.
Weil das äh macht jeder Staat äh.
Ja, die werden sich da auch äh die werden sich da auch jede Einmischung gerade von Deutschland äh verbitten. Ja, also wenn dann Deutschland ankommt und sagt, hm wir sind aber beunruhigt und die Ilse Eigner äh ja, die läuft schon rot an,
Da sagen die einfach uns auch egal, wie ihr damit klarkommt.
Macht euch doch einen eigenen Google.
Ihr werdet jetzt hier nicht äh genau.
Ja, denke mal nicht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwelche Änderungen machen, nur weil ihr da irgendwelche Bedenken habt. Ja, Bedenkenträger.
Na ja, gibt's jetzt noch irgendeinen äh äh Aspekt, den das äh wichtig wäre zu beleuchten?
Nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, wir können, wir können mal weitermachen. Also, spannend ist, dass ich das jetzt noch hier immer noch neuere Sachen rauskomme. Äh Breaking
und das äh entgegen den meiner gerade kurz geäußerten Vermutungen, dass das alles von dem Snowden kommt, scheint es äh so zu sein, dass jetzt auch einfach weitere äh und das wäre natürlich spannend, äh zwei ehemalige NSA-Chefs, die also jetzt auch noch von anderen Sachen da sprechen, ja?
Also es wäre ja jetzt mal spannend, äh,
Also John Maike, ehemaliger Direktor und Meike Hayden, auch ehemaliger Direktor. Haben jetzt auch ähm.
Sich geäußert über eben diese ähm über die diese äh Hackerangriffe, die halt von der von der NSA ausgeht,
Spannend, vielleicht äh wird er jetzt äh viel drüber diskutiert. Ich denke aber viel mehr als äh äh Awareness,
Wird da jetzt gar nicht ähm bei rauskommen. Also ich denke nicht, dass sich da irgendwas dran ändern wird. Da bin ich mir.
Nö, das glaube ich jetzt auch nicht, nee.
Ähm am achtzehnten, neunzehnten sechsten ist dann der Obama in äh Deutschland zu Besuch.
Angela Merkel sich mit ihm unterhalten. Ich denke mal, sie wird sich dann beklagen, dass es dass es da nicht ausreichend deutsche Technologie zum Einsatz kommt bei dieser Überwachung, denn wir haben ja dann auch ganz vorzeigbare Hersteller für,
Hardware die für so was gebraucht wird und.
Ich vermute auch einen harten Schlagabtausch im Hinterzimmer mit Wattenbäuschchen. Ja. Da wird richtig.
Ja Vater, harter Austausch äh von äh Klopfen auf die Schulter, ja. Er wird hart. Gut.
Vermutlich. Gut. Wir spulen vor. Was haben wir noch?
Ein Update äh von Lobbyplug. Lobby Plug hat die Plattform äh fett geupdatet, wie.
Lobby Plug, wir haben's hier schon geplagt.
Ja ähm Lobby und Paste, also die Plattform, die ähm.
Versucht exemplarisch aber nicht ausschließlich nur damit mit der neuen Datenschutzverordnung
mal nachzuweisen, wie so die Wege des Lobbyismus auf EU-Ebene konkret laufen, eine Plattform, die eben die Änderung an Anträgen versucht zu tracken und auch zuzuordnen, zu,
einzelnen Abgeordneten, um mal herauszubekommen, was da jetzt eigentlich genau geht,
ähm fleißig weitergearbeitet. Es gab ja da auch ein Funding, ein Crowdfunding, was äh erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurde und das scheint durchaus auch Wirkungen zu zeigen.
Ähm ich kann jetzt im Einzelnen nicht sagen, wer jetzt da an diesem, an diesem neuen Release am meisten zugetragen hat,
so oder so die Gruppe als Ganze wird da Energie reingesteckt haben, sitzt aber vor allem auch 'ne Softwareänderung, wenn man auf die Webseite geht,
dann kriegt man jetzt auch noch so eine hübsche Auswertung, eine grafische Auswertung, denn dieses ganze äh Änderung pro Datenschutz äh Kontradatenschutz, zumindest jetzt mit dieser spezifischen,
Brille, die man jetzt äh in dieser Gruppe darauf hat, ja, weil kann man ja lange diskutieren, was jetzt pro oder kontra ist, aber,
eben mit dieser Bewertung, deren Aussage sich auch äh auf der Plattform nachvollziehen lässt, wird eben jetzt ähm hier mit Rot und Grün,
schön eingefärbt, sowohl die Länder Europas,
Das heißt, man kann sehen, welche Abgeordneten äh also aus.
Aus welchen Ländern die Abgeordneten kommen, die jetzt mehrheitlich äh pro oder contra
dieser ursprünglichen Datenschutzverordnung gestimmt haben. Also wir erinnern uns ja der erste Ansatz wurde ja von Bürgerrechtlern als sehr positiv
ausgelegt und im weiteren Verlaufe durch diesen vehementen Lobbybeschuss von allen Seiten,
diese ganze Datenschutzverordnung eher in einen allgemeinen äh Freispruch machen zu können, was man möchte,
und äh diese Visualisierung auf Lobbyplug, die gibt jetzt einfach ein bisschen mehr Überblick. Da gibt's dann auch gleich einige Überraschungen, wenn man äh da drauf schaut, finde ich zumindest, ja, also dass hier zum Beispiel
wie Deutschland, Frankreich, auch Österreich und interessanterweise auch Bulgarien, Portugal und,
ähm Griechenland hier äh grün eingefärbt werden während der Rest eher schlechter abschneidet.
Wie gesagt, das ist aber jetzt nun ein Zusammenfassung aller Abgeordneten. Man muss das dann schon auch nach den Fraktionen äh sich genauer anzuschauen, anschauen, äh sie haben's dann auch aufgebrochen für die einzelnen,
Personen, das heißt, es gibt dann 'ne Top Ten Pro und Contra, ja wo dann interessanterweise auch wieder Deutsche voranstehen äh auf der ähm,
Seite der fürs Rechte und Gerechte kämpfen dann die Gerechtigkeitsliga sozusagen.
Seite ist das, also.
Hätte ja jeder so seine eigene Sicht, also im äh im Grünen Lager sind dann auch äh Grüne ganz vorne, Jan-Philipp,
Albrecht äh wird hier genannt mit einer.
Der der Berichterstatter zu dem Ding, ne?
Genau, da ist er sehr engagiert. Ähm wenn man da halt mal draufklickt.
Jan Philipp Albrecht führt mit
hunderteinundachtzig für stärkeren und vierunddreißig für schwächeren Datenschutz. Äh die Liste jener an, die am meisten für einen stärkeren Datenschutz machen.
Während seinen Kollege Axel Voss Deutscher ebenfalls, ähm,
CDU, ja, äh derjenige ist, der am meisten mit hundertsechsundsiebzig Amens am meisten,
für die Schwächung des Datenschutzes sich einsetzt. Dazu wurde er dann auch äh interviewt,
Und das sind jetzt, wie sie, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
Ach so, nee, das sind dann die von ihm eingebrachten Änderungen. Auf einem anderen Blatt steht da nochmal, wer die alle geschrieben hat.
Genau, also man kann es.
Hatte ja nicht selber.
Für jede Person äh sich das im Detail äh anschauen. Es gibt dann halt so einen kleinen Kreis, Grafik eben diese Zusammenfassung, also wie viel
pro Contra und wie viel neutrale Vorschläge hier eingearbeitet wurden. Und dann eben auch eben, wie schon vorher, eine lange detaillierte Liste
dann eben auch mit dieser äh Einordnung, wo man dann eben auch ganz konkret sehen kann, was das ähm,
nun wahr, ja? Also, was wurde konkret an welcher Stelle äh geändert? Also man hat immer diesen Diffiew, das gab's, glaube ich, so in der Form auch schon vorher,
ähm neu ist halt jetzt diese ganze Prokontra Bewertung. Da kann man natürlich dann immer noch anderer Meinung sein, ja, ob eine bestimmte Formulierung, eine bestimmte Änderung jetzt auch wirklich diese Aussage verdient, dass es eine Verschlechterung darstellt,
Wie gesagt, äh in großen Teilen der Lobby wird das sicherlich genau andersrum gesehen. Ähm so oder so, aber eine interessante,
Ergänzung dieser Software.
So sieht's aus. Kann man gerne klicken, wieder wieder mal super Arbeit.
Genau, Crowdfunding at Work. So.
Dann äh gab es, wir wollten da beide hingehen, haben's aber nicht geschafft, den Fachdialog Netzneutralität im Wirtschaftsministerium? Nee.
Du hast es auch nicht geschafft. Naja, ich war dann die Woche gar nicht da. Mhm.
Ähm da war dann also nur, um es jetzt es ist, da ist jetzt genau das passiert, was ja auch äh so befürchtet äh,
wurde. Da standen dann der breit, der Bundesverband der Breitbandkommunikation Anbieter und der VATM. Jetzt fragst du mich genau wieder, was VATM heißt, kann ich mir immer nicht merken, Verband, der Anbieter von Telemedien, glaube ich
Ähm Mediendienst. Äh der VATM auf jeden Fall. Ja,
äh Verband der Anbieter von Telekommunikations und Mediendiensten. Mehrwertdiensten. Mehrwertdiensten, ja klar. Man kann sich vorstellen, wenn schon Mehrwertdienst im Name ist, was deren Einstellung zur Netzneutralität ist
Ähm da wurde also würde der Herr Grützner äh vom äh VATM äh zitiert, dass ja das Best-Efod-Prinzip nun mal nicht für den Erfolg des Internet stünde
sondern für seine technische Unfähigkeit äh bestimmte äh Übertragungsqualitäten zusichern zu können.
Ähm der Kunde wünsche sich diese aber und sei auch bereit, dafür zu zahlen. Klar, wenn ich Leistungen einschränke und sage, du musst zahlen, um die wieder zu bekommen, dann zahlen die natürlich. Ähm deswegen führt ein Überholspuren im Netz kein Weg vorbei,
Aber er ist sich ganz sicher, man darf dann nicht in die Netzneutralitätsdiskussion hineinkommen.
Dann würde man ja da vielleicht diesen Formulierung auf die Spur kommen,
Ja, das finde ich äh schon mal interessante Form des ähm modernen revosionismus, ja, also dem Internet äh zu unterstellen, das best afort.
Nicht zum Erfolg des Internets bald getragen hätte. Also das finde ich schon wirklich haarsträubend, weil,
Genau das ist nämlich das, was dem Internet auf technischer Ebene äh äh den Siegeszug äh überhaupt ermöglicht hat, ja, gerade also es ist wirklich hanebüchen.
Ich finde, ich finde es viel freudiger zu sagen, es führt kein Weg an Überholspuren am Netz vorbei. Dabei müssen wir aufpassen, nicht in die Netzneuralitätsdiskussion hineinzukommen. Was ist also weißt du so, was soll das denn?
Na ja, weil da würde man sich wahrscheinlich verstricken.
Wir müssen die wir müssen die Netzneutralität äh aufweichen, aber da dürfen wir nicht in die Diskussion kommen äh hier wegen Netzzentralität. Weil das ist ja weiterhin die, die bleiben ja auch genau bei dieser Ansicht, dass das neutral bleibt. Also.
Ich kann dem nur hinzufügen. In dem Moment, wo Metaphern äh angeführt werden, die irgendwie mit Autobahnen oder Fußball zu tun haben, dann äh,
muss man sehr gut aufpassen. Dann ist wahrscheinlich schon der ein oder andere Spin unterwegs, ja?
Ja
Insofern würde ich halt sagen, der der Herr ist also hier mal direkt ins Abseits gelaufen.
Ja und äh hat da wohl seine Argumentation nicht die richtige Ausfahrt genommen.
Ähm,
Das Kartellamt ähm hat aber angekündigt, sie wollen sich das mal anschauen, also in die Netzbundesnetzagentur prüft ja auch schon diese Drosselpläne,
Und das Kartellamt sagt, na ja und das ist, denke ich, auch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, äh wenn nicht sogar der,
Also ich sage mal, es ist aus aus meiner Perspektive auf
Welt und wie sie sein sollte nicht der wichtigste, ist aber aus meiner Leinperspektive auf äh auf äh juristische Gegebenheiten wahrscheinlich der erfolgsversprechendste, dass sie sagen.
Ähm ihr wollt äh Inhalte, Anbietern, äh Wettbewerbs Wettbewerbsvorteile verkaufen,
indem ihr denen diese Managed Services gebt und äh und dadurch automatisch andere Benachteiligen
ihr habt außerdem noch selber Aktien in der in der Inhalteanbieter Sache. Das klingt doch mal nach etwas wo das Kartellamt ähm
Ahnung von hat und wo man sich damit auseinandersetzt. Ja, welche Folgen das für den Wettbewerb hat. Ich halte ähm,
das also für sehr äh interessant, dass sich das Kartellamt da mal äh auch mit auseinandersetzen wird.
Mhm. Nee, das ist ähm.
In der Tat interessant. Ich meine, die Telekom hat versucht sich da, glaube ich, selber schon so ein bisschen rauszu äh holen, ja? Also sie meinten ja, dass äh,
Videolot, also dieser eigene Video On-Demand-Dienst von der Telekom sehr wohl da mit in die Datenmenge reingerechnet wird, ja? Also so ein bisschen geahnt scheinen sie schon äh zu haben, dass
sie da jetzt nicht beliebig vorwerfen können.
Deswegen wollen sie den Laden jetzt einfach dicht machen oder was, ne?
Na, es steht also doch so ganz sicher scheint sich die Telekom noch nicht zu sein, wie es mit Videolaut weitergehen soll.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist äh am Ende des Tages ohnehin ein Flop wird, dass
äh wissen wir, glaube ich, eh alle, ja, wenn es so besonders erfolgreich diese ganzen Lots ja auch nicht gewesen, also ich glaube, ein Musical Load ist jetzt keine keine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Mega Upload.
Ja ja finde sowieso, man sollte sich mehr um den Upload kümmern, also um den Download. Na ja, also äh.
So viel dazu. Also äh das das Ding kocht da so vor, köchelt da so vor sich hin, ähm man kann da jetzt hoffen. Es gab äh übrigens ein ein enorm interessanten ähm.
Äh äh netzpolitischen Abend der digitalen Gesellschaft äh äh in der vergangenen Woche
in der dann Benz Gott sprach, Ben Scott hat maßgebliche Rolle gespielt bei der Netzneutralitätsdiskussion
in den ähm in den USA und den daraus dann der daraus entsprechenden Legislative,
Die ich persönlich ja trotzdem noch kritisch sehe, aber ähm der hat da sich sehr gut geäußert,
Clemens war auch zu Gast, hat sich auch nochmal zu diesen zu den Drossel und Netzsachen geäußert. Den kann man,
da durchaus nochmal ähm empfehlen, ich suche das gerade mal raus, da gibt's ja ähm.
Sicherlich auch wieder ähm Aufzeichnungen von. Habe ich noch nicht gefunden. Link folgt oder kann man wahrscheinlich irgendwie dann oder auf digitale Gesellschaft DE finden.
Ja, machen wir weiter. Haben's dann schon angesprochen, Bradley Manning,
jetzt grad wo sie neue Whistleblower mit aufs äh Feld kommen,
seinem äh Fall wird vor allem darüber diskutiert, ob er denn nun einer ist oder nicht oder ob er nicht einfach nur ein ganz böser Soldat ist, der seine Loyalität, seine Eingeschworene gegenüber dem Staat missbraucht hat,
Ich denke, dass es so im Wesentlichen erstmal die Linie, die sich jetzt beim Prozessauftakt gezeigt hat.
Ja aber er steht halt vorm Militärgericht, insofern weiß ich nicht, ob die Debatte da noch länger äh,
längere Zeit geführt wird, weil der,
Chefankläger sagt ja, also du bist ein, du bist eben nicht irgendwie ein Whistleblower, Zivilist, sondern du bist halt ein Geheimnis verratender Soldat. Und da gibt's hier nicht irgendwie Whistleblowers oder so. Das Ding, was wir hier machen heißt Militär.
Mhm. Aber er hat ja.
Diesen ganzen Prozess beginnen, schon mit einem Teilgeständnis äh begonnen, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, so geschickt äh formuliert, dass eben all das, was ihnen so richtig in die Scheiße reiten könnte, nämlich sozusagen,
Töten könnte, dass das erstmal um umschifft wurde, ist das irgendwie akzeptiert worden mittlerweile, oder?
Ja, also das äh weniger wegen seiner weniger wegen des Inhaltes seines Teilgeständnisses, sondern.
Tatsache, dass es überhaupt gemacht hat.
Tatsache, dass er es gemacht hat ähm er hat dazu geführt, dass das Gericht von der Möglichkeit der Hängung, der Verhängung, der Todesstrafe Abstand genommen hat. Das heißt, der Mann äh fürchtet nicht mehr um sein Leben,
sondern nur noch äh darum, äh wie er den Rest seines Lebens verbringen wird.
Übrigens, sei da nochmal äh auf auf einen schönen Artikel verwiesen mit dem Titel
Insight äh United Stays, wo jemand im typischen Duktus,
ähm Peter Gerling hieß er im typischen Duktus wie hier in der westlichen Welt über Unrechtsregime berichtet wird, über die USA geschrieben hat,
Wo er dann auch sagte, Bradley Manning, der da irgendwie gezwungen wird, äh nackt ohne Kopfkissen zu schlafen und so, ne? Und dann ähm also mal das ein ein das sollte man gelesen haben. Das,
äh das habe ich äh als Link zu dem zu dem Thema Prison dabei, aber ich füge es auch nochmal unter dem Bread Day Artikel.
Denn natürlich zieht sich diese Sache schon auch so ein bisschen weiter. Also Prozessauftakt äh gegen Bradley Menning, die ganze Nummer wird jetzt ungefähr ein Jahr lang dauern.
Urteil gesprochen wird? Kann man mit rechnen, dass äh das dauert?
Na gut.
Ansonsten ähm wir haben hier schon lange drüber diskutiert. Äh DE Mail, äh das äh kommende Desaster der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Du warst ja selber da Experte.
Ich war da Experte zu.
Versuchen, versucht noch irgendwie Einsicht zu erzeugen, bei irgendjemanden.
Ich habe versucht, ihn da zu erklären.
Ja, aber offensichtlich war,
jetzt keiner dazu bereit, so hat auch der Bundesrat das durchgewunken, das doch eigentlich viel einfacher ist, die eigenen Sicherheitsstandards zu senken, anstatt äh mal die eigenen Gesetze, bei denen man sich irgendwann mal was gedacht hat, auch äh einzuhalten,
und deswegen ran jetzt die E-Mail auch irgendwie in Betrieb gehen mit ja muss jetzt nicht so sicher sein, weil wir haben's ja nicht besser hinbekommen.
Genau, das ist das äh Gesetz. Ähm,
Also da geht's um die Kommunikation mit äh Ämtern und Behörden von Bürgern. Ähm dieser zweite äh dieses zweite Gesetz ähm,
wo es dann um die um die Gerichte ging
wo ich dann auch noch bei der zweiten Anhörung war, äh wird dann vermutlich bald folgen, ja. Opposition hat geschlossen äh gegen die äh dagegen gestimmt. Ähm haben auch äh im Bundesrat dann nochmal zu,
zur Begründung relativ äh relativ textsicher,
zu meinen Argumentationen da meine Argumentation vorgetragen,
ähm ja äh oder was heißt meine Argumentation? Die die Argumentation der Ratio vorgetragen.
Wo kommen wir denn da jetzt hin, wenn man jetzt immer über alles richtig nachdenken würde und.
Genau, also wir haben jetzt ein ein völlig peinliches äh Gesetz und äh dürfen gespannt sein, ob das jetzt irgendwo zu irgendwelchem äh.
Ja, aber was was kann schon Großes passieren? Also ich meine, du verschickst dann halt eine Mail. Die wird dann halt bei dem übertragenen Telekommunikationsunternehmen dann auch wieder äh unverschlüsselt weitergereicht. Äh
Ach so, waren das nicht die Unternehmen, die sowieso alles weiterreichen, wenn jemand mal vorbeikommt und sagt, äh schickt mir das doch mal.
Ich hab's ja immer, ich hab's ja immer gesagt, es ist natürlich eine Sache, die man, die man in so einer Stellungnahme dann nicht schreibt
weil man ja da äh da bin ich als technischer Sachverständiger ähm der Grund dafür, dass die D-Mail nicht vernünftig sicher ist, ist ganz einfach, dass du als,
als Staat doof wärst, ein sicheres Ende zu Ende verschlüsseltes äh Komplikationsmittel anzubieten und zwar jedem. Du willst doch hier deinen Prison machen und deine strategische äh Kommunikationsaufklärung ähm
du machst, das macht man nicht,
strategische Fernmeldeaufklärung heißt ja dieses BND-Programm. So und stell dir mal vor, die NSA geht hin oder oder der BN äh die Bundesregierung geht,
Bundesregierung oder USA gehen hin und sagen, ey hier, übrigens äh sicher Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation für jeden, yay.
Warum hast du dich nicht als Sachverständiger für die CDU aufstehen lassen oder die CSU?
Mich nicht angefragt.
Ach so, aber das wär doch auch sehr schön gewesen, wenn du da einfach mal ganz klar
so argumentiert hättest. Ja, also das äh kann man ja jetzt nicht sicher machen, weil wenn man das Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln würde, dann würde ja dem Staat die Möglichkeit fehlen, an allen möglichen Stellen da strategisch Daten äh im Geheimen zu sammeln und.
Das ist der Grund. Also das, das ist ganz offensichtlich der Grund. Es ist ganz klar.
Und das ist irgendwann mal anders drin stand im Gesetz, war eher ein Unfall.
Stand ja nie stand ja nie anders drin. Es stand ja immer drin, ja, man kann auch Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln über D-Mail,
kann man, kann man über jede, wie ich bereits erklärt, über jedes Kommunikationsleben, ich kann eine Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte SMS an dich senden.
Allein, es gibt keinen, du müsstest die dann irgendwie Hand entschlüsseln oder oder ähm
Ja, also so so sieht's aus. Wir es passt eigentlich wunderschön in diesem in diese Meldung mit dem oder in diese Erkenntnisse mit dem Prison ähm mit rein. Ähm da sieht man das, ja. Das wird natürlich nach außen anders verargumentiert, aber das äh ganz offensichtlich.
Dass äh und ich würd's, ehrlich gesagt, im im äh im Linusismus würde ich's mir auch nochmal überlegen.
Ob ich äh zumindest von von staatlicher Seite äh so eine Möglichkeit äh bieten wollen würde. Als als Diktator jetzt, ja.
Oder in einer Demokratie.
Schalten wir nach Brüssel auf der EU äh Ebene wird aber nicht nur sich nicht um unseren Datenschutz äh gesorgt, sondern ähm da gibt's dann auch noch diese Sache mit diesen Hackertools.
Ja, Hackertool-Verbot.
Ja, das ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter eigentlich die ganze Geschichte. Ich weiß nicht, hatten wir das überhaupt schon mal hier? Nee, das nee, ne?
Nee, deswegen habe ich's ja mit äh mit aufgenommen. Ja. Ähm das.
Fiel mir, oh je. Ähm.
Also böse, böse Hackertools, die die Welt unsicherer machen, müssen unbedingt verboten werden und das ist die Vorlage äh im EU-Parlament oder wie.
Oder wird das noch im Ausschuss bearbeitet, was.
Also ich habe mich da, da habe ich mich äh mit mit Andre drüber unterhalten, der ja auch den Artikel auf Netzkritik org dazu geschrieben hat. Ähm,
Es geht im Prinzip ja so um um das um das Gleiche, was wir in Deutschland auch schon haben, den den äh den Hackerparagraphen, ja?
Dass sie sagen, okay, wir wollen Hakatool-Verbot äh in, in, in, in der Form haben, dass wir sagen, die Nutzung.
Ähm oder die Verbreitung von diesen äh von diesen Tools ähm äh stellen wir unter Strafe.
Ähm.
Ja, aber welche Tools sollen denn jetzt ähm da bestraft werden?
Ähm Tatwerkzeuge.
Also Hackertools dürfen nicht hergestellt verkauft, beschafft eingeführt, besessen, verbreitet oder verfügbar gemacht werden. Wenn sie dem Zweck des Eindringens des rechtswidrigen Eindrings in Informations,
Systeme dienen. So und das ist natürlich jetzt so eine äh oder oder also äh nee, Moment. Also
Hackertool ist ein Tool, das rechtswidrigen Zugang zu Informationssystemen oder Systemeingriffe oder Eingriffe in oder das Abfangen von Daten,
ermöglichen. Da steht aber jetzt noch das Wort rechtswidrig drin. Und wenn es ein Tool.
Äh wenn ein Tool dafür diesem Zweck Dienst rechtswidrigen Zugang,
zu irgendwas zu haben, dann darf es nicht äh Verkauf, beschafft eingeführt, besessen, verbreitet oder verfügbar gemacht werden.
Ja, jetzt wäre natürlich die Frage, äh reicht es aus, dass ich an meinen Hackertool sage, dran schreibe, dieses Tool dient nur dem
scannen auf Sicherheitslücken oder dieses Tool.
Der ist äh sollte nicht, darf nicht benutzt werden äh für rechtswidrige Tätigkeit,
Umgeh ich das Problem damit schon? Das ist ja das das ist ja also die Hauptsorge dabei ist ja es klingt ja erstmal nach einer guten Idee. Es kann ja nicht sein ja? Es kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass äh Hackertools auch noch legal sind.
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass du den Leuten ähm äh Brechstange im im Baumarkt verkaufst, mit denen sie äh dann Häuser aufbrechen,
Das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Ähm.
Es gibt Brechtsteinen im Baumarkt, ja und es gibt auch äh auch Messer im im Porzellangeschäft. Ähm.
Das gleiche Problem hat man natürlich bei den Hackertools auch. Und zwar natürlich gerade in der äh Branche, in der ähm.
In der ich ja auch tätig bin, ist das natürlich enorm notwendig, auf solche Tools zurückgreifen zu können, um eben äh Systeme zu prüfen. Ja, ähm,
Uns an dem äh Müller Magun damals noch als CCC-Sprecher, hatte das schon vor vor vielen äh Jahren äh so gesagt. Ähm,
Testangriffe zum Auffinden von Sicherheitslücken sind für die IT-Sicherheit wie Crashtest in der Autoindustrie.
Ja
Niemand käme auf die Idee, Crashtests zu verbieten.
Libertäre Amerikaner haben einen sehr schönen Spruch, den der äh der wunderbar ist. Sie sagen ganz aroutlad, only out.
Also in dem Moment, wo ich wo ich äh Waffenbesitz kriminalisiere, haben nur noch kriminelle Waffen und ich als äh Patriot kann mich gegen diese Kriminellen nicht mehr wehren.
Das ist jetzt die beste Argumentationslinie ist.
Ich meine, wenn du wenn du hier wenn du die zigtausend Toten, die die jedes Jahr äh auf der Straße liegen haben mit fünf Kugeln im Rücken, wenn du die wert ist als äh als die als die Verteidigung eines Patrioten gegen Kriminelle, dann äh kannst du das natürlich
Argument bringen, ne. Also genau, aber das ist eine ist eine ist eine.
Ist in dem Fall eine unsinnige Argumentation, weil es eine ähm weil es eine Polizei gibt,
Aber die Idee einer einer äh Hackerangriffspolizei äh zu der wir dann gleich auch noch kommen, äh kannst du dir halt auch an den Hut stecken,
Ja also ähm das der.
Es es ist niemandem geholfen, wenn man äh zum Beispiel auch das das Publizieren von von Sicherheitslücken unter Strafe stellt, ja, passiert ja regelmäßig, dass jemand hingeht und sagt, ähm.
Was unsicher.
Da und da ist was unsicher, ja. Und dann wird da auch wieder der der äh äh der Boot, der der Boote erschossen, ne.
Vor allem schafft es eine extreme äh Rechtsunsicherheit für Unternehmen, die halt in diesem Bereich überhaupt arbeiten wollen, weil sie ja potentiell immer Gefahr laufen, dass ihre Mitarbeiter, ne, so als was weiß ich, gelten. Bösewicht.
Jetzt zeigt der der Hacker äh Paragraph in Deutschland, der ist ja bis heute glaube ich nicht zur Anwendung gekommen.
Ich habe zumindest noch nichts davon gehört.
Nichts von gehört, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich das mit als erstes gehört hätte.
Mhm.
Ähm.
Also mal wieder so ein Gesetz fürs Regal, ja.
Es es ist.
Nur weil ich's jetzt beschlossen habe, müssen wir das ja nicht unbedingt gleich durchsetzen.
Es ist ziemlich bescheuert, aber das ist halt dann wieder eine Richtlinien, äh dann hast du halt direkt gegen ganz Europa diesen Quatsch.
Also das ist äh also es ist keine Verordnung, ne, sondern eine Richtlinie. Wir hatten den den Unterschied ja mit mit Hilfe von Kirsten Fieler schon mal.
Erläutert. Aber es ist.
Es ist äh ein ein weiteres Beispiel dafür, wie wie völlig inkompetent äh mit mit dem mit diesem Thema äh umgegangen wird, ja. Eine weitere Sache, die äh die debattiert wird.
Ist ja die Meldepflicht für Cyber-Angriffe,
Ja, in Deutschland nicht mehr. Das äh kriegt man nicht mehr durch diese Legislatur. Da wurde es aber natürlich auch äh besprochen, da ist die, die rationale ist, dass ich als Unternehmen ähm.
Wenn man angegriffen wird, dass man das dann auch melden muss.
Dass man das melden muss und die äh die der Gedanke, der dahinter steht, ist ist gar nicht so blöd, dass man sagt, wir wollen den den Austausch,
Ähm das Wissen über die, die tatsächlich stattfindenden Angriffe ähm.
Sammeln und teilen, ja, um einen besseren Überblick dafür zu bekommen, ja, um die
und um wenn einer einmal einen Angriff erfahren und abgewehrt hat, dass dass dieses Wissen geteilt wird, ja, dass wir dass wir eine quasi so eine Art,
Immunsystem aufbauen äh und zwar äh in ein in in einer Gruppe. Das macht des äh BSI, das das Ziel strebt das BSI ja an mit dieser ähm.
Allianz für äh Cyber-Sicherheit, die wollen ja auch genauso etwas machen. Ähm.
Das ist natürlich relativ schwierig ähm.
Weil das so das ist, das sind so Gruppen, wo du eigentlich, also das hier so ein, so ein Game Fear Problem in dieser Gruppe,
Ähm du hast als Mitglied dieser Allianz eine sehr guten,
Wenn du Glück hast, viele Informationen, die du als als Sicherheitsbeauftragter deines Unternehmens äh wieder mit in deine Organisation hineintragen und dort zur Anwendung bringen kannst. Das heißt, als still dort sitzen und zuhörender, kannst du,
sehr gut profitieren davon,
Das Ganze funktioniert aber nur, wenn es auch Leute gibt, die in dieses, in diese Gruppe hineintreten und sagen, Freunde, so und so haben sie uns hier gerade maximal erwischt
echt mal ein Wochenende stark geschwitzt und ich da ähm.
Aber wir haben so und so abwenden können, ja? Das heißt, automatisch, dass du dich vor diese Gruppe stellst und sagst, hier ich habe äh ein Sicherheitsproblem,
Ja? Und das ist die Kultur ist bis heute äh die Kultur ist heute noch nicht da, dass äh dass man so etwas freimütig,
zugeben würde, ja? Ähm weil natürlich ähm.
Bei den Firmen natürlich Angst haben, dass es dann irgendwie so in die Medien äh sickert und wenn es dann mal wieder heiß hier, Firma XY
ja große Hackerangriffe finden statt alles in Gefahr denken sich dann halt die potenziellen Kunden so hm,
Da ist es ja wohl nicht so toll, wobei man halt, weil nicht unterschieden wird zwischen Angriffe und äh.
Erfolgreicher Angriff, ja? Ich meine, das jetzt äh Attacken et cetera oder eben auch konkrete Hackattacken stattfinden, ist ja das eine. Die Frage ist, wie gut ist man dagegen äh geschützt, ne?
Insofern scheint, also wäre jetzt so meine äh mein Gefühl, diese diese ganze Cyber-Allianz-Nummer da, die scheint nicht so richtig zu funktionieren
und deswegen kommt liegt natürlich dann der Gedanke nahe zu sagen, okay, wir machen jetzt hier eine Meldepflicht. In Deutschland, wie gesagt, kriegen sie halt nicht mehr durch die Legislatur. In der äh auf EU-Ebene wollen sie genauso was machen.
Und wollen dann eine zuständige,
Eine Ei, also ihr ihr Modell ist dann eine zuständige nationale Behörde, eine einzige. Wieso das BSi? Das ist ja auch in Deutschland genau diese Allianz für Cyber-Sicherheit Nummer dann da versucht, auf die Beine zu stellen. Ähm.
Und jetzt ist aber, jetzt kommt genau das ist ja auch genau der Konflikt, dem das den das BSI unterliegt. Jetzt schließt sich hier so der ganze Themenkreis. Ähm,
sie wollen, sie sollen einerseits irgendwie für die, für die Sicherheit des Bundes äh oder der Bundesrepublik irgendwie verantwortlich sein, sie bringen da ihre komischen Papiere raus und erklären, was irgendwie
ist und so. Sie sind aber haben gleichzeitig inhärent das Interesse diese äh die Bürger zu einem gewissen Maße,
unsicher die Systeme der Bürger unsicher zu halten, denn sie wollen ja äh nicht äh Plattformen für Terroristen, die
ja? Und das das siehst du genau bei den, bei, bei, bei, bei bei D-Mail, bei diesem Secure Cloud Ding, was wir hier vor einem Jahr mal behandelt haben, dass sie da eben nicht äh nach, nach, nach maximalen Sicherheitsstandards ähm,
da etwas schreiben, sondern immer noch äh im Hinterkopf haben, wir müssen irgendwie oder unsere Geheimdienste müssen irgendwie am Ende doch noch drankommen?
Und ähm der eigentliche, das eigentliche Angreifermodell, was wir hier haben, ist, dass uns die Daten ins Ausland abwandern.
Und dann da den den Geheimdiensten der anderen Länder äh ohne dass wir wissen in welcher Form äh unter Kontrolle liegen. Das ist dieses einzige,
Der einzige äh Triebmotor äh bei bei solchen BSI äh.
Seid ihr völlig schizophren? Ja, auf der einen Seite will man äh irgendwie alles sicher genug machen, damit Deutschland sozusagen nicht leidet
ja, so als Wirtschaftsstandort oder was auch immer
Aber dann bitte auch nicht ganz so sicher, weil wir wollen ja zumindest auch noch selber äh die Möglichkeit haben, hier irgendwo reinzugrätschen. Und ich glaube, das sind auch so zwei Ansätze, die sich nicht miteinander verheiraten lassen. Das,
das geht einfach in die in die falsche Richtung und es wäre sicherlich sehr viel klüger und konsequenter, wenn man einfach sagen würde, ja, bestimmte Dinge,
lassen sich eh nicht verhindern, zumal eh auch immer wieder gilt. Wer.
Kritische Kommunikation hat und die äh absichern möchte, da gibt's mehr als ausreichende Möglichkeiten, das zu tun, ja.
Das muss man selber machen.
Die großen Terror-Plotz werden äh bestimmt nicht über Facebook organisiert, ich will nicht ausschließen, dass nicht irgend so ein Depp,
Ja, auch so was äh macht und leider sind auch grade immer diese Fälle, wo dann eben schnell über Äußerungen auf solchen Plattformen et cetera potenziellen Tätern oder eben auch Tätern, die auch
durchaus was ausgeführt haben, ja, hier weiß nicht ganz genau, diese Bombenleger da in äh Boston haben wir auch die ein oder andere Spur hinterlassen,
Natürlich, in dem Moment kommt man dann auch wirklich an Informationen. Aber es ist auch gar nicht gesagt, dass man an dieser Information nicht über andere Wege auch gekommen wäre. Naja.
Also nochmal zu dieser zu dieser Cyberangriff Meldepflicht ähm.
Grundsätzlich erstmal eine eine ganz sinnvolle Idee aus der erstens informiere informiere mal bitte die Kunden, ja? Da haben wir sowieso dann nochmal diese äh.
Auch informiert so eine so eine zentrale Koordinationsstelle. Das macht ja durchaus Sinn.
Ist äh ist durchaus sinnvoll, hat aber, wie gesagt, dieses, du hast dann da so ein so einen kleinen äh Konflikt für alle, die da drin sitzen, weil eben jemand, der da nur drin sitzt und nix sagt, der profitiert halt maximal,
Und deswegen kriegst du diese Kultur nicht hin, dieses die Kultur des offenen Austausches, zumindest nicht skaliert die nicht auf so eine große Allianz, wie du dann da eigentlich,
bräuchtest. Und jetzt wollen sie mit irgendeiner Pflicht kommen. Das wiederum bringt sie aber äh vor das nächste Problem, denn wer ähm,
Also wo setzt du die Grenze, ja? Also drücke ich jetzt hier äh
einmal auf die Leukanone gegen äh gegen die Allianz äh Webseite. Da passiert noch nicht mal was,
die müssen aber dann irgendwie fünf Seiten fünf Seiten Bericht schreiben, dass sie ein ein Griff von Linus Neumann abgewehrt haben,
Ja, also ab welchem Punkt definierst du an an welcher Stelle definierst du, äh dass es jetzt ein meldepflichtiger Angriff? Das wiederum und das ist eine sehr
fein
feine Definition, die er vornehmen muss. Äh das wiederum kann halt äh wenn du da, wenn das unsinnig machst, äh dazu führen, dass da dass die, dass die äh Unternehmen dann da gelähmt werden und irgendwie zwanzig äh Berichteschreiber irgendwie in
in ihrer,
In ihrer IT-Security-Abteilung haben, das wiederum verwässert aber dann auch das Ziel, was du da eigentlich hast. Also es ist eine ist eine schwierige Sache, um in der EU-Richtlinie ähm.
Und Meldepflicht äh weiß ich nicht ähm.
Wie gut du das am Ende äh umsetzt. Ich glaube, dass äh es vermutlich da dann doch der der äh.
Zumindest, wenn's um, wenn es wirklich darum geht, dass die eigene Infrastruktur sicherer wird, dass da der kleine
informelle Informationsaustausch zwischen Verantwortlichen dann doch zielfrierender ist. Was die was die betroffenen Bürger angeht dann doch eventuell so 'ne so 'ne Meldepflicht,
weil das ist ja auch, also da sage ich noch ganz kurz, was so, das ist ja tatsächlich das Problem, dass ähm Unternehmen dazu neigen, insbesondere dann, wenn Kundendaten betroffen sind, da
nicht äh sofort tabula rasa äh äh nicht sofort alles offen zu legen. Ähm die Leute irgendwie im Ungewissen zu lassen, äh Schaden in durch öffentliche Berichterstattung irgendwie vermeiden zu wollen
Das ist äh hier sicherlich auch ein ein ein sehr großes Problem. Und das sind zwei verschiedene Problemfelder, die man nicht mit einer Verordnung ähm,
kann, deswegen steht hier auch etwas ähnliches wie diese Meldepflicht auch in der EU.
Gut, ich denke, damit haben wir die Sendung abgefeiert.
Leider keinen großen Erfolge zu vermelden. Ähm ja, wir sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen regelmäßiger, oder?
Wir sind, wir sind jetzt regelmäßiger.
Äh ab genau.
Ach so, ich wollte noch äh danken. Es ist ja jetzt äh schon einige Zeit her, der mein äh meine äh Flatter äh Einkünfte haben sich erhöht.
Aha.
Statistisch signifikant in im letzten Monat erhöht,
reicht noch nicht ganz neues MacBook, aber das war ja auch überhaupt nicht das Ziel. Also vielen Dank,
und dann hat er, glaube ich, noch jemand in den Kommentaren geschrieben, dass die äh Tasche ja so schön ist und er, die, die jetzt bestellt hat, die ist aber noch nicht bei mir angekommen.
Na sowas. Na sowas. Okay.
Also vielen Dank äh für die äh für die Unterstützung da in Zeiten der der Note.
Not. Genau. Das war's. LNP siebenundsechzig. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.